because this is how I roll and I'm
selfish I'd like to have friendlies all
around me marshal so I reached out to my
dear friend Charles Barkley to call in
because Charles nothing makes me smile
like you so welcome back onto the show
what's up merry Christmas to you guys
and the rest of the world Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas to you too Charles
you just got off a flight I can imagine
after watching those games last night I
just talked to Shaquille who was busy
cooking in his kitchen for a cooking
show because he's not busy enough and he
was making the following he was making
ribs macaroni and cheese fried chicken
what else Marshall lamb chops pork chops
and there's his giant fingers in there
trying to flip over some pork chops I
mean this is scary my question for you
is what can you make me for lunch I'm a
grill guy first of all if you think he's
cooking all that stuff he might have
somebody there cooking it boys no we
have him on tape Charles we have him on
actually on tape cooking it himself well
I tell you what I can't wait to see that
tape in that show Susan I'm a griller
I'm not great in the kitchen but I'm
great on the grill I can get you the
greatest food ever might be a hot dog
okay Organic is not even my thing
I think we can put like an extra $5 on
the yeah III really don't believe
there's anything organic it's just like
let's just call it organic because
people in California yeah they'll pay
extra for everything yeah because I
always tell people people have been
doing this stuff for a thousand years
and they didn't drop their regular
now when people want to talk you more
they throw organic on there or non-gmo
whatever the hell that means I love it
they got they got another scam gun going
by they call it Google yeah I can't
figure it out Chuck I've been I'm like
so you've been shopping at these stores
before there was a Whole Foods but now
you could you only go to Whole Foods so
they could charge you double the price
okay all right my daughter calls Whole
Foods whole paycheck right because it is
what would you use to eat when you used
to carbo-load up for a game and I'm
saying that with all due respect to
Marshall and me do you oh I two pretty
ladies a large fry and I washed it down
with a diet coke and Marshall product
notice to like these guys today they be
going on vegan and it's crap like that
I'm like young man on the way home from
practice I grab me two fish fillets a
large fry and I wash it down with a diet
coke and I never worried about the
carbo-load and all that other crap if
you can play you can play I'm a firm
believer in that listen if you can't
play well I did see her cardio last
night and racing to the go to the big
screen back there I gotta get out of the
blocks I gotta call the great Edwin
Moses somebody like that and suck and
work on getting out of the blocks won't
you call Rich Eisen maybe he can give me
you made 40 nope no I've seen you rich
my trust me
yeah richest man out of the blocks he's
running out a living with me are you
kidding this way starting to run faster
and faster alright let's talk about 30
seconds of basketball before we just
continue with it with it just total mess
it will usually be an interview that we
do
Yanis last night when you watched him
play we talk every once in using all
these big word
and fancy sings were passing the torch
and what-have-you are we making too much
of it or was last night a monumental
night in the Association well I don't
think it was just last night I mean he
is - reigning MVP he's not taking he's
taking the torts he's not asking for it
it reminds me of like a Michael Jordan
and obviously all talked about that you
know a member that time when it was
magic and bird Michael says none enough
I'm taking the torch thank you all for
everything y'all did for us but now it's
my time now and Jonas is doing that I'll
listen LeBrons great James Harden's
great you know Katie's a great player
when he comes back but Yanis is taking
the toys I mean here's a guy who won MVP
and it's gotten better over the summer
he's making threes I mean you know we
you know think about it we said last
year he couldn't shoot now he's shooting
he's making threes and he done took the
torch he's the best basketball player in
the world
I mean Kawhi Leonard agreed also but
Yanis is the best player in the world
right now and not only that team he does
- Michael remember when Michael was the
best player he's the best offensive
player
Yanis is probably the best offensive
player we got to in create that's what
make him double great so let's let's
move it forward and I can can Yanis in
the Bucs
and Yanis being the only super start at
the Bucks have Kenny Kenny Kenny when
Kenny win the title well there's three
teams that can win a title in my opinion
that's in the box and there's no
particular other Lakers and the Clippers
own two three elite team they have
separated themselves from the other
teams in the NBA
yo Phillip deputy has been a
disappointment Utah has been a
disappointment but no walk is head it
shows above everybody in the East and
the legs and the Clippers are all the
two teams in the West as you can see
yeah one of those teams going to win the
West I mean Denver has not played great
Utah like I said you talk about a
disappointment call
been a disappointment but listen the
Lakers and the Clippers are head and
shoulders above anybody in the West so
should the Lakers get Andre Iguodala is
that enough well you know I actually
said that last night not on the air I
was talking with Kenny I said man if the
dollars don't be huge for somebody
because the Lakers bench is not even
comparable to the Clippers Vince
I mean Harrell and Lou Williams the
Lakers don't have anybody like that but
you know it's a dollar if he comes back
to the levy go to he's don't help but
he'd be a great pickup for the Lakers
but like I say it's a legitimate
Clippers in the West Canton shows above
everybody and when you look at how a
team has put together Charles I mean
obviously you and I talked a lot last
year when I was doing a show for the
Lakers and I'm looking at at their bench
in their depth and it seems to me that
yes they have ad they have LeBron James
but they've put together a steadfast
strong deep bench for the Clippers that
is its it doesn't have to be as big of a
name it has to be consistency coming off
the bench and that's what we're seeing
and like they may have a loss last night
but they had two guys get ejected for
fighting which is let's just say like
you know that if they hadn't been
ejected as a solid shot diverse won that
game yeah you know I'm not sure what
happened last night that was kind of
weird like wow I was I don't know what
luly's went crazy for and I saw Doc
Rivers said you know they lost their
composure but listen the Clippers they
probably have Williams is the best best
player in the NBA and Harold man his
energy level is through the roof I love
watching him play but Lou Williams man
he is unbelievable
the Lakers they don't I don't what's
coming interest is the kind of Kuzma
situation how they use him he might be
the guy they have to use coming off the
bench because he's not gonna get a lot
of shots if he's out there with LeBron
and he D he might become a Lou Williams
type guy
comes in he just got car blunts it just
let it go anytime he'd get it but right
now the Lakers in the the the Clippers
bench is much better than a Lakers bench
and you know he got a lot of looks last
year because he had to they needed him
look says nobody else was out there he's
also a little injury prone don't you
think well I think listen he's not gonna
play those killer minutes I mean because
now you got you got two of the best
players in the world and Paul and Kawhi
so he don't have to have such a he's not
gonna have to play those killer minutes
because you know last year they weren't
very good he had to play pretty much the
whole game and now he can be selective
so that's gonna help him stay healthy
and and be more effective hey Charles
when you look at the league just I know
you say only three teams have a chance
give me one other team that if they get
a piece or let's say the superstar
decides to play like a superstar that
they have a chance who would that be
oh it's easily the Philadelphia 76ers if
you're LMB play like he's capable of or
bensonmum picks up his level that's the
only other team can get in the
conversation you got two guys who can
dominate a game anytime they're on the
court but they're inconsistent but it's
JoEllen being and being summoned that's
the only other team I see could get in
the equation because I could say you
know
Yanis don't have no running mate but if
if a bead and Simmons start doing their
thing they got two great players against
one and obviously two great players
compared to one gives you an advantage
but don't let other team I see doing
that is Philadelphia I think it's just
too easy to ask you about 2lm bead I
mean I mean every single show on the
planets ask you about in this week about
what why he's got a bee in your bonnet I
said this when I was doing my quail
bones and and and Tony Clips party in
eruption which is a great show to it by
pay people and Marshall knows this your
best players
and it sounds stupid when I say it your
best players have to be your best
players like well Marshall was the best
running back in the NFL it he he wasn't
anyone gonna survive with the backup
Marshall had to be Marshall Faulk yeah I
mean I think I think some people like yo
man you our best player be our best
player you can't ask role players and
backups to be your best players and care
you every night that's why they're role
players and backups they're not as good
as starters so I challenge OLM beid be
the best player on the court every night
listen when you watch them in walk in
Bucks play you know Yan is gonna be the
best player on his team and on the court
most night and then everybody else is
going to follow but if your best player
is out there and he's not gonna be the
best player every night your team is not
going to win because Susie the NBA is
different than other sports and what I
mean by that is you know you when you
have to win four out of seven this is
not a one-and-done scenario where a role
player or a bench guy can go crazy one
night and still a football game or pitch
a great game in baseball I have a great
night in hockey in the NBA you have to
beat a team four times in a week and if
your best players don't they don't lead
you you're not going to win it's plain
and simple well he's clearly listening
to Charles because his play picked up
since you said that all to him who do
you like for the weekend for the
National Football League because I know
you have your eye on that league as well
I got a house in Philly so I'm an Eagles
fan and I can't wait for that game it's
those two teams the Phillies had a bunch
of injuries this year the Cowboys I
don't know what the hell's going on down
there I mean you got a terrific
quarterback you got a great running back
you got a great wide receiver and you're
seven and seven so that's gonna be
must-see TV this weekend I can't wait to
watch the game but the other game I'm
watching I gotta watch the bills against
the Patriots
because I want to see if there's a
changing of the guard I mean and this
might be this might be the end of the
Patriots dynasty yeah baby they have not
played well they defense been amazing
tom is not playing great this year but
this might be if they lose this game at
home I think it's fair to say it is over
for the Patriots and I and I know a we
probably said that before but this time
it seems a little bit different because
you know Tom who's the greatest football
player ever ever and like I said he's in
a conversation with Tiger as the
greatest jocks of all time I think you
could I tell people Tiger Woods is the
greatest golfer maybe the greatest
athlete uh but Tom Brady is in that
conversation but you know he says you
want to play to play these 45 and
Marshall teller we all want to play to
afford a 9 but we quit abate but we
click for a reason to smile the time is
undefeated and I'm ELISA and like I said
I don't know at some point you just
can't play anymore and I tell you what
if the Buffalo Bills are able to go into
Foxborough we're in that game I think
it's the end of the dynasty well we will
see if Santa brings one more one more
question I know you a huge college
football fan what has it been like
dealing with Shaquille with LSU God
playing the way they playing right now
oh yeah it started that week and then
he's been unbearable but but you know
what it's such a good story with that
burrow kid yeah you know not getting to
play and his speech at the Heisman
Trophy and I see they've raised like two
in the $50,000 for a homeless people
shelter in his little hometown which is
even more amazing he's an amazing kid
yeah but you just love to see somebody
who's so humble who played great all
year and deserve the - trophy but
thinking about other people and I tell
you what he did that was amazing me
watching that speech oh but you know
what I have to do Charles believe it or
not I have to cut you off because we're
gonna go dark in five seconds I'm saying
merry Christmas to all of you we are
appreciative to all of you stop by I'm
sorry to cut off your job speech Omar
thanks to Shaq thanks to Emmett thanks
to Marshall thanks to you all Merry
Christmas for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app